[Musique]
bon vous en doutez je suis pas là pour
faire la peinture de la scène
j'ai appris une fois que une image
valait 1000 mots alors c'est dans le
thème de la soirée c'est une limite ma
limite pour la soirée que je vais
revenir un petit peu plus tard là-dessus
alors j'ai beaucoup de chance ce soir
d'être devant vous et vous avez aussi
beaucoup de chance d'être là ce soir
et je vais rester en tout cas pour les
10 prochaines 18 prochaines minutes
pourquoi j'ai beaucoup de chance parce
que normalement on va dire une personne
comme moi a une très grande chance de
finir soit dans une chaise roulante
soit finir de manière handicapée d'une
partie du corps ou alors en dépression
dans le meilleur des cas en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on voit sur les groupes
facebook on connaît l'étiquette qu'on
met au groupe facebook malheureusement
quand vous êtes dans une situation où
vous apprenez une mauvaise nouvelle ben
vous vous raccrochez à ce que vous
pouvez vous raccrocher à part les
médecins vous comprenez absolument rien
c'est Internet
alors laissez-moi vous raconter mon
histoire simple personne comme vous tout
a débuté en 2018
j'avais enfin obtenu on va dire un job
qui payait bien auquel je devais
travailler très tôt à très tard 6h à 22h
21h 22h le reste du temps je pouvais
être avec ma famille tout allait bien on
était épanouis on savait que c'était une
période on va dire temporaire
car on avait beaucoup de travail puis
après ça allait aller mieux on avait
planifié des vacances on pouvait enfin
espérer avoir des vacances après avoir
quand même travaillé dur et puis envoyer
le soleil
au travail on peut dire et pour ceux qui
me connaissent je me sentais invincible
ça allait bien
je travaille bien
en tout cas de mon point de vue et puis
tout allait bien
jusqu'au jour où j'ai senti un petit peu
comme une chaleur à l'intérieur de moi
c'est bizarre je dois couver une maladie
ça devait être au mois d'octobre je me
suis dit j'ai attrapé froid c'est pas un
problème
j'ai l'impression d'avoir vraiment de la
fièvre et puis après quelques jours ça
c'est un petit peu compliqué je me suis
réveillé un matin
et je sentais un peu les fourmillements
du côté gauche de mon corps
j'étais un petit peu bizarre du côté
droit c'était très différent c'était un
petit peu Cotonou quand je touchais en
fait je sentais pas mon la partie droite
mais tout fonctionnait bien je dis bon
ça va passer
je me suis peut-être fait mal au dos
j'ai peut-être fait un peu le con en
faisant du sport à gauche à droite j'en
sais rien mais je me suis pas inquiété
plus que ça et puis les jours passés et
plus à mon travail je me déplacer
bizarrement sur les derniers jours ça
ressemblait plutôt à ça
alors faut être motivé le matin pour
aller travailler dans ces conditions là
alors les collègues vous regardent avec
des gros yeux puis vous dites ouais à
force de frotter le pied par terre vous
commencez à avoir d'autres douleurs
alors j'ai été voir le docteur
monsieur Renard après les examens
plusieurs jours on s'est absolument pas
ce que vous avez bon d'accord moi non
plus ça tombe bien
ça va passer
c'est inquiétant quand même docteur ça
va passer oui ça va passer effectivement
je me suis mis en arrêt de travail
pendant deux mois et après deux mois ça
a passé gentiment lentement mais le côté
droit j'avais toujours cette sensation
j'ai dit bon c'est pas normal on sait
jamais j'ai peut-être un truc je sais
pas où j'ai continué j'ai continué
d'explorer on va dire d'investiller avec
mon médecin les possibilités que pouvait
y avoir jusqu'à ce qu'il m'envoie chez
un neurologue au moins je suis un
neurologue c'est tout de suite
catastrophe là haut déjà que ça tournait
un peu bizarre mais alors là je me dis
ouais super
IRM prise de sang ponction lombaire j'ai
eu la totale après quelques semaines je
me retrouve en face de mon neurologue
bilan je suis bien assis dans le
fauteuil tout va bien je me sens bien je
dis j'ai rien de nouveau ça va bien
aller et là mon docteur m'apprend que
j'ai la sclérose en plaques
à ce moment-là votre vie se fige un bref
instant mais elle se fige un peu comme
dans les films vous avez tout qui passe
devant vous il vous explique et il
enchaîne quel médicament serait bien
pour vous vous ne comprenez déjà
absolument pas ce que vous avez quand
vous explique déjà comment ne pas
arriver à vous guérir alors ça va très
vite on peut pas me guérir ok on prend
des médicaments ok ok et là vous
ressortez un peu du docteur vous accusez
un petit peu ce qui vous arrive alors
sclérose en plaques moi j'ai dû me
documenter pour vous je vous ai mis un
petit dessin pris sur Internet première
ressource sur laquelle je me suis penché
vous avez le petit neurone auquel on a
beaucoup qui reliée par enfin jusqu'au
muscle qui sont reliés on va dire par le
système nerveux entouré d'une certaine
substance qui s'appelle la myéline
et votre corps
il se dit tiens j'ai rien d'autre à
faire
je vais détruire mon corps donc les
globules blancs vont commencer à aller
manger cette myéline et quand les fils
se touchent ça fait qu'on circuit et ça
commence à malfonctionner dans le corps
voilà pourquoi ça arrive des fois qu'on
se déplace un peu bizarre
alors certes
ça se guérit ça se résorbe pour une
partie des cas ce qui est mon cas mais
ça laisse des séquelles alors les
séquelles que j'ai c'est que la partie
droite quand je saute dans la piscine
froide pour moi elle est chaude du côté
droit alors ça c'est un des avantages
l'avantage c'est que l'hiver je peux
sortir en cuissette j'ai pas froid
voilà donc je sors chez le médecin chez
neurologue et puis un peu abattu je suis
sur internet je regarde un petit peu en
ce que c'est ça je regarde aussi sur
Facebook les groupes qui me tirent
plutôt vers le bas que vers le haut
et puis je me dis ben ça alors je suis
mal barré et je tombe sur une annonce
appelle au casting vous êtes sédentaire
vous voulez courir un marathon de 42 km
en 6 mois
ça tombe bien j'ai toujours voulu courir
dans ma jeunesse je l'ai jamais fait
pour la simple et bonne raison que c'est
fatiguant puis c'est long je me suis dit
pourquoi pas aujourd'hui Pourquoi pas
puis après je me dis mais pourquoi j'ai
jamais fait ça avant
ben j'étais un petit peu plus enveloppé
que maintenant donc je me disais c'est
pas très sexy un type enrobé qui court
sur la route et puis bon ça fatigue non
demain puis demain ce sera demain puis
demain ça demain puis 43 ans plus tard
vous changez
vous changez d'intensité dans la tête je
peux le dire aujourd'hui et je remercie
c'est malheureux de dire comme ça je
remercie ce neurologue qui a pu trouver
déjà ce que j'avais mais la sclérose en
plaques m'a fait commencer à vivre
c'est à partir de ce moment-là que j'ai
fait vraiment les choses pour moi
et la première chose à faire ça a été
cliqué sur appel au casting donc j'ai
postulé de toute façon je me suis dit
que la chance que j'ai je n'aime jamais
rien je vais jamais gagner ça c'est
clair donc en toute confiance j'ai
appuyé sur le petit bouton
malheureusement j'ai été pris
alors un jour le téléphone sonne c'était
le coach
textuellement ça fait vraiment comme ça
dring
oui SALUT c'est Pierre hey salut pierre
ça va et là dans ma tête c'était ko
alors écoute Sacha on a bien réfléchi
on va décider on a décidé de te prendre
textuellement j'avais répondu oh merde
tu es pas content d'être pris si si si
pas de problème mais pour une fois je
gagne quelque chose je dois courir
voilà c'est comme ça que j'avais mon
premier pied
à l'intérieur du système course
alors bon on s'est retrouvé on a
retrouvé la team des gens super sympas
je me dis bon il y en a qui sont fusées
pour la course moi pas c'est bon je peux
me mettre un petit peu en retrait ça va
être simple c'était pas simple trois
entraînements par semaine plus un 10 km
un semi-marathon un 30 km avant les 402
les mensonges sur la fiche c'était
marqué que 42
alors certes le premier pas le plus
difficile que j'ai rencontré à faire ma
première limite ça a été de mettre les
baskets alors on peut être un super bon
coureur on peut aller jeter le matériel
qu'on veut chez Decathlon ça fera pas de
vous le bon coureur on voit pas mais
j'étais habillé tes 4 ans de la tête à
pied
je suis sorti et j'ai fait les 100
premiers mètres ça a été les 100
premiers mètres les plus durs de ma
quarantaine à chaque maître ouais
retourne à la maison c'est pas encore
trop loin retourne à la maison c'est pas
encore trop loin retourne qu'à partir de
100 mètres ça a démarré
c'est pas encore du plaisir parce qu'il
m'a fallu une année avant d'avoir du
plaisir pour courir donc on sert un
petit peu et on y va c'est pas facile
mais on s'accroche 10 km j'avais un but
ne pas s'arrêter bien sûr je me suis
arrêté au bout du kilomètre j'étais
fatigué j'arrivais plus j'avais plus de
respiration je me suis arrêté j'ai
marché le reste
21 km semi-marathon en plus c'était une
course officielle avec les caméras qui
sont à côté de vous vous avez un grand
portrait de vous en train de souffrir à
la télévision parce qu'en plus il y a
une tendinite je vous explique un petit
peu quand vous voyez ouais c'est moi
c'est moi
fallait pas s'arrêter je me suis arrêté
donc tout ce qu'on m'avait donné comme
but jusqu'à présent j'ai pas réussi 30
km et c'est là que j'ai commencé à
comprendre beaucoup de choses sur moi
passe 30 km c'est long de bout en bout
vous avez le temps de réfléchir alors
plus vous courez vite moi vous
réfléchissez moi j'ai eu le temps
d'écrire un livre
j'ai souffert pendant ces 30 km j'en ai
même pleuré
mais quand vous réfléchissez à une chose
quand vous réfléchissez qu'au dernier
anniversaire de votre fils
c'était raclette en plus ça tombait bien
moitié paralysé
imaginez je suis un peu dur là-dedans je
voulais absolument servir la raclette et
racler je vous laisse imaginer
et c'est là qu'on réalise et qu'on
réfléchit tout ça en courant
que votre petit-fils de 3 ans
qui avait son anniversaire
vous pouvez pas faire comme ça pour le
prendre dans les bras parce que vous
avez une moitié du corps qui fonctionne
plus et là vous réfléchissez
quand vous voyez votre femme que vous
pouvez plus prendre dans les bras vous
réfléchissez
et vous vous dites mais j'ai foutu quoi
ces dernières années
c'était quoi les priorités
et ben pendant les 30 km il y a beaucoup
de choses qui se passent
et vous trouvez des réponses fort
heureusement aujourd'hui ça va mieux je
peux prendre mon petit garçon
et il a grandi donc la plus besoin de
bref ce site en dit
c'est pas parce qu'on vous met des
limites je pense que ça ça gêne tout le
monde devant vous en semaine au propre
limite toutes nos déducation depuis tout
petit jusqu'à Toulon à l'école on vous
fait faire un 12 minutes qu'est-ce qui
arrive après 12 minutes
c'est terminé donc on vous on vous met
dans la tête c'est la performance il
faut faire de la performance vous avez
12 minutes pour faire la meilleure chose
de votre vie à la course ok 12 minutes
aussi dans les examens on met des notes
c'est la performance c'est une course à
la performance constamment toute la
toute notre vie et puis petit à petit on
construit ses limites
ce soir on met un rond rouge je mets une
limite blanche par terre je pense
qu'elle gêne tout le monde on sentira
nettement mieux si je l'enlève ça j'en
suis sûr déjà il était pas parallèle
pour la simple et bonne raison
que nous sommes nous nous sommes nos
propres limites on a tous une éducation
différente
et ça fait de nous notre capacité tout
de suite on voit tout de suite les
sportifs à mon avis ils ont jamais de
limite parce que il court certains si
vous prenez sur les Ultra trails moi
j'en ai eu beaucoup déjà tant de 43 ans
pour courir c'était une très grande un
très grand effort pour moi
donc c'est 30 km voyelles sont longs et
beaucoup de choses qui se passent dans
la tête
après les 30 km on fait un petit retour
sur soi on se dit OK
j'ai souffert
les limites n'existent pas ou très peu
je dis pas si on a mal ça c'est clair ça
peut exister mais je veux dire les
limites les grosses parts de limite
qu'on a
elles sont pas là donc j'ai parlé avant
de performance
il y a d'autres moyens de réussir il y a
les réussites j'ai choisi aujourd'hui de
courir pour des réussites de terminer ce
que je commence je peux être dernier
deuxième ça m'est égal mais cette finir
c'est d'aller au bout la différence d'un
bon j'ai cru au début qu'un bon coureur
c'est un coureur qui allait vite
pour moi un bon coureur c'est quelqu'un
qui commence et qui continue et qu'il a
le pouvoir de continuer
comme nos rêves mon rêve ça a été
toujours de courir j'ai jamais fait
juste à ce qui est une émission et là
j'ai décidé de continuer continuer vers
mes rêves
vous verrez ça finit pas
bien sûr après les 30 km il se passe
quoi
le 42 km alors c'est encore un petit peu
plus long que le 30 km c'est 12 vous
l'aurez devinette espace aussi même si
c'est une course il se passe aussi
beaucoup de choses dans votre tête
donc 42 km
39 de souffrance
trois de plaisir
en six mois c'est normal mal aux pieds
mal au genou
certains me disent mais tu as dû
beaucoup sacrifier de choses pour
arriver à courir 42 km
non rien tout le temps entre guillemets
sacrifié ça a été un investissement un
investissement pour ma santé
je vais nettement mieux qu'avant comme
il dit que j'avais la sclérose en
plaques déjà je suis un petit peu plus
sportif je cours un petit peu plus je
suis passé de sédentaire à maintenant je
peux dire je cours pour le plaisir
donc si vous avez compris vous me
comprenez vous comprenez aussi que
certaines limites dépassées c'est clair
que certains sujets de ce soir parlent
d'autres limites
il y a d'autres possibilités d'autres
courses la vie continue après ces 42 km
on appelle ça des rêves ou des buts à
atteindre plus ou moins long terme
j'ai continué pour mon corps j'ai
continué pour ma tête
alors je dis pas que c'est facile je dis
pas que demain on peut tous aller courir
mais vous devriez ça fait du bien ça
fait du bien parce que là dedans ça aide
à discuter sur pas mal de choses
alors avant de terminer
j'aimerais juste vous dire qu'il faut
vous autoriser à faire des choses à vous
autoriser à dépasser des limites
car les limites de vos capacités ou les
limites de votre potentiel sont à la
frontière
j'ai oublié le mot
de vos croyances voilà exactement
et c'est là c'est dur en toute cette
entraînement durant tous ces 42 km y
compris des autres courses que j'ai fait
que j'ai pu comprendre ce que ça voulait
dire les croyances limitantes
et puis maintenant que j'ai compris ça
je me suis fixé un autre but un autre
rêve on continue on ne s'arrête jamais
c'est l'année prochaine de courir les
250 km dans le désert du Sahara
je vous souhaite une chose si vous avez
envie
et je sais que vous avez sûrement envie
à votre façon cette courir votre propre
marathon
bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]